hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it so you don't boo be that I
mean boobies with the boobie boobies but
the people be boobies yeah today's film
is barbed wire
now you remember hearing about this that
Pamela Anderson comic book movie about a
superhero who also happens to be a
stripper it's just like that god-awful
cartoon she started stripper Ellen you
know the had the exact same premise of
the superhero stripper except where
stripper ella was a horrible piece of
horseshit barbed wire is there is no
difference between barbed wire and stick
around it's blatant it's stupid and the
only reason it exists is because Pamela
Anderson has boots much large large
large boots for the some reason you
forgot that the film reminds you
positively don't believe me let's dive
right into the shitstorm and find out
why this film is so bad okay let's take
a look at our very first opening see ya
you starting to see why this movie was
made
oh I forgot to mention there's also a
boring backstory right off by the
narrator the old democracy is overthrown
by a tyrannical new group called the
Congressional Directorate every city in
the nation is under martial law except
every city in the Neches under martial
law except one steel Harbor the last
free city a secluded island
it is a placemark thirteen crime
providing a home for a new kind of
mercenary blah blah blah the future
sucks boys
Oh
I wonder anyone's even reading the
credits right now
oh wow the music was done by man in fact
I would be shocked if they just added
credits just to keep this scene going
long
get it all
so just when you're praying the whole
movie is nothing but this the flat
sailing rears its ugly head oh I know I
know just try to get it over with so our
hero barbwire lives in a festering
hellhole known as steel Harbor which
takes place in the apocalyptic world of
I guess so Baba wasn't the change we
needed we see her working at a strip
club that she entertains the owner who I
swear is a mix between Peter Lorre and
the Fantasy Island guy what are you
doing here looking for a light got one
uh-huh I don't smoke neither do I I
always smoke when I start something
horrible so it turns out she's a bounty
hunter who's sent in to the strip club
to say the kidnapped girl
I'm the ones getting you out here
we better may go wait tooling ever see
Batman depends whether or not he's
affiliated with the comic this movie is
based off goddamnit
as you can see Pamela Anderson is the
Shaquille O'Neal of acting shy Oh
goddammit - shit
come on I'm angry Leigh Leigh so she
gets the girl - her parents a plan to
pay her handsomely but there's one
little problem
cut the shit where's my money I could
only come up with half the money fine
I'll take half your daughter yeah
what so they make a deal by trading
their car for the rest of the money as
Miss wire has a monologue about why
things are the way they are it was the
middle of the second American Civil War
the worst year of my life we're all I
knew how to do was pose on top of cars
port steel Harbor what a shithole mean
why don't we come - why don't we start
again whose sexual psyche do we just
dive into
now where's dr. Corrina Devonshire and
please answer in the most titillating
way possible I told you I abhor danger
but your words just don't match your
thoughts should I be watching this
okay movie you clearly have some sexual
issues uh tell me when did these
fantasies of torture enter your mind
well our thinking was when my mom first
took me to a strip club so the bad guy
doing all the torture Inc is known as
colonel pryzer and he's out to find a
scientist named dr. Cora D apparently
she devised some sort of contact lenses
that can protect your identity so the
government can't track you this will
prove useful to a resistance that is
fighting against this fascist government
that is currently taking over the world
not enough of that bullshit here some
more - so barb is not only a stripper /
bounty hunter but also owns a strip club
called hammerhead just look at the
futuristic dance
we also come across Bart's blind brother
named Charlie oh I guess hangs out there
quite often Chanel number five
am i correct yes you are when I smelled
that I thought to myself Charlie now
this is obviously a woman of significant
breeding then I thought I wonder if
she'd like to do some reading that is
you like that pickup line I got it from
guide post in Braille of course
meanwhile just outside the club dr. Cora
D and her husband named Axl get stuck at
a roadblock look we just stick with the
plan okay change of plans
well I finally figured kill my fucking
car so even though we never see them
exit the vehicle and they have nowhere
to go
Thanks somehow it's scale after that we
see barb exit the strip club on her way
to another job and she makes her way to
another monologue I had to do a little
moonlighting to keep my bar running not
an easy life a girl's gotta do what a
girl's gotta do come on this isn't an
apocalyptic future
it's a stir damn you seem to step
outside of toy stores so she plays
herself off as a hooker which let's face
it is not very hard and she gets herself
into the room next door to another
person she's supposed to bring in called
crimps hmm why don't you go change into
something a little more comfortable how
about something a little less
comfortable oh it's the law stood her me
a noogie noogie noogie did you wash your
hands no I was big
don't you know being knocked out with my
fetish so she burst into the room next
door and shoots up a bunch of bed
you're my last bill jumper Cruz wake up
sunshine
that was nice kicking you really know
you stuff me what did you call me oh
yeah I forgot to mention she hates to be
cold babe
now slut hooker bitch whore those are
okay but if you call her babe that's
just sexist don't call me babe oh maybe
I should have actually attacked her with
a knife and such as standing here so
barb is also friends with the head of
police named Willis who often look the
other way to her illegal doings as long
as he's well compensated and I do mean
well compensated hmm of course not oh
that's sexual harassment chief and I do
have to take it
listen barbara kopetski we could play
this little cat-and-mouse game all night
long but I have more important things on
my mind like how the hell do I get out
of this piece of shit movie we've been
cut to this rather unnecessary moment
where some drunk guy tries to get into
the club during the day just give me my
drink sir we're not open yet I think
you've had enough already
ah Bomi okay don't blow her off get her
off of me
that's Camille
yeah gives new meaning to the term fetch
the balls
kamil outside well enough of that point
let's see more boobies
but the stretch show will have to wait
as the club is infiltrated by M Bisons
twin brother of course if Cordia escapes
I will personally rip your heart out of
your ass and stuff it back down your
throat that doesn't make any sense I
will personally rip your heart out of
your ass right after I rip your lungs
from your ears and shove them back in
through your nose so they talk with barb
to see if she knows the whereabouts of
dr. Cordy well I guess it's hard to find
somebody unless you know what she looks
like her present appearance is of no
consequence identification can always be
made by retinal scanning so hey I wanted
um doc just close up - excuse me boss
traveler in the kitchen so it turns out
Cordy enters at the exact same time the
colonel does but that doesn't get Barb's
attention well gets her attention scores
husband Axl who used to be Barb's lover
and I never wanted to hurt you
now's not the time to explain we're
three years late Axl get out don't come
back wait let me recap this a fascist
government is looking for a scientist
and spouse working for resistance who
take shelter in a bar under management
by the spouses ex-lover and a corrupted
cop hmm now where if I heard that before
Casablanca
I mean wow there's like no difference
the plot is literally just Casablanca
why why you're both present Lanka do you
really think that nobody would notice
did you think that arguably the most
famous romance film of all time was so
low on the radar that no one would make
that connection granted the tedious work
of distraction but I can only hide so
much I
what would Humphrey Bogart have to say
about this all the film flubs and all
the cinema and all the world she had to
rip off my car jumping pitch so okay
returning to Casablanca - here's looking
at you slut we see axel talk with
Charlie before he confronts barb where's
Bob I don't think talking to Barb's
gonna be such a good idea
too late three two
one next I'll do my ABCs so barb turns
them away but Charlie leaks them to the
center of the resistance led by a woman
named spike the congressionals took the
lenses they did this know the
congressionals are still looking for
Christine on that for sure
we'll listen the local cast on this
Friday third one too many Winston
cigarettes The Flintstones lied to me
hey babe good meanwhile the Carlin gang
continued their search as they burst
into a bail bond service to get some
answers
you're all under arrest we needed to
make an interrogation sorry sir they
resisted they dared to ask us what's
going on so they read the minds of one
of the dead men however the hell that
works as they believe the answer may lie
in barbed wires Club meanwhile we cut
back to Barba she all right you know
what this is this is centerfold the
movie you can take every other scene in
this film and just put it on issue of
Hustler anything I wasn't preventable
was running into you he'll get over it
so Axl tries to win barb over the fine
she's one stubborn female who's gonna
top it all out or not am i interrupting
something
well not now hi hi hi um I was just
making sure her mouth wasn't bug bomb
this is my wife Cordy how impressive I'm
sure you'll have very strong smart
children if they stay out of future
sequels they will be I was just better
left a part of your past
oh so that's wedding can invitation to
your wedding a barb there's more to this
story than meets the eye
the Autobots waged the battle to destroy
the evil forces of the Decepticons
but they were again interrupted by the
colonel and his crew I think this guy's
only job is to walk into buildings
dramatically who are they I picked them
up off the boulevard I like a good
menagerie now man scan him
luckily Charlie has some sort of machine
Messer upper thingy that stops the ID
machine from identifying though sir the
scanners broken search it wasting my
time get out oh hey boss you don't be
really funny if they were the people we
were looking for you know like the one
time our scanner machine doesn't work
and it was the time that we actually
found them and we just let them go we
would look so stupid but that'd be
ridiculous
so the soldiers decided to search the
area thoroughly actually maybe a little
too thoroughly
yes neons make sure they're not hiding
in the martini glasses I wish you could
see this miss I couldn't see when it was
clean but Charlie has a little surprise
what the hell were they looking for
anyway stupid contact lenses like these
we can get into axial and help them
escape
not so fast this is our ticket to Europe
hey they don't belong to us
Finders Keepers you're making a mistake
barb it's not just about money you know
I knew Charlie was still friendly don't
monologue around me I'm still here oh I
also forgot to mention this film has a
fetish for cutting to black and fading
back in
I keep thinking every time they're going
to fade to black something goofy is
gonna suddenly appear so she takes the
context to a crime overlord simply
called mr. big fatso I'm guessing they
call him that because he likes Dom
DeLuise movies you didn't drive all the
way to the heart of the evil empire to
see how my diets go you came here to
talk about the contact lenses didn't you
I'm in a position to broker their sale
that's what I hey hey Fat Albert will
make him an offer he can't refuse
meanwhile Charlie gets captured by the
colonel I was subjected to its course
you've seen that's not quite as
titillating there be openings where are
the lenses this guy has it what guy
he's fat wears a red suit
white beer
means crinkle yeah
yeah put a search out on this Kringle
guy so barb finds her Kentucky Fried
brother is Axl and Cordy arrived on the
scene Charlie what just Jigga's my fat a
bar being the thoroughly unlikable
character that she is still wants to
hand over the context of mr. fatso where
unfortunately the kernel is there
waiting not only do I get the menus I
get a million dollars bounty on your
head and I'm $1 body on the head of the
good doctor to turn you both over to the
Congressional don't you just move yeah
let's give our conference lips Pharma
grenade that these guards should clearly
be able to see and she uses it to escape
but god she's got a grenade
Hey shit
one bar finds out she's not getting any
money her morale suddenly return as we
partake in a pretty standard chase
but the colonel gets to jump on her with
a bulldoze
the joke has on a monster
ah the medic station into the depressing
station is this the one that makes it go
up and down yeah yeah dad which one
makes it go around that one right here
about this one dude then you use that
brain thing my momma told me about
normally I don't get emotional about my
work the vaporizing you're springy ass
is gonna be a real pleasure you forgot
so a crane being run by axel actually
picks up the cart and bulldozer in what
I have to admit as a pretty creative
action sequence you know about sometimes
you got to take a step back and ask
yourself just hold on hell did I get
here
I got you babe everyone don't I'm going
I'm going
that's worth laughing over so the
villain is destroyed as they tried to
get the doctor and the contact lenses to
safety and wouldn't you know it it ends
with them saying goodbye outside of a
plane gonna miss your friend so I
thought Bob whenever took sides figure
to yourself he's ripping off you kid
where will you go
while the hair Paris is nice this time
of year bearish this could be the end of
a horrible do believe on long and loved
get in line oh okay I guess the movie
shot itself before it appropriately yet
as well as should this movie is horribly
stupid it stunts are standard its lines
are boring its acting is corny and of
course it's fucking Casablanca my
recommendation see fucking Casablanca is
considered one of the greatest films of
all time I mean what could this movie
possibly have that Casablanca did
boobies
I'm under static I remember it so you
don't have
is a deal